[Music]
what if I told you that one man's
mustache to bring down a 300 million
dollar superhero movie where would you
rank supermen in the annals of
superheroes the greatest superhero of
all time number one across the board I
don't think the mustache compromised
Superman at all
we don't believe Ben Affleck can really
jump off buildings like that it's all
about the suspension of disbelief
Collider moustache boys productions
present Superman stache the follicle
fumble honestly look we told those dopes
at Warner Brothers if you want cavil
he's got to keep the stache they went
for it
idiots I guess gonna fix it in post I
hope in summer of 2017 reports of heavy
reshoots for the Justice League movie
surfaced as did pictures of Henry Cavill
with a thick mustache for his role and
Paramount's newest Mission Impossible
film that's when variety broke the news
that Warner Brothers would not be able
to get a clean shave and cavil for the
reshoots with I fist I wasn't pissed I
what yeah sure yeah I was I was yeah but
I figured you know if they could CGI
Robert Downey do you need to look 21 and
how hard could it be right it's easy you
just it's like whiteout with CGI right
nobody ever consults with the VFX
Department you think the idiots over
there on mount stupid are just saying Oh
fix it in post fix it in post
oh yeah cuz look how simple it is
shouldn't have to eliminate a mustache
my name is Mark n Draco and I am a Henry
Cavallo gist do you get paid for this
only spiritually can you walk somebody
through the daily life of a Kabbalah
gist spending time going through like
Getty Images and weird fan sites and
seeing what sort of illustrations have
been created by people on the internet
that did betray Henry seeing the photo
of Henry Cavill with the porn stash in
the Superman costume well let's say just
check the boxes I didn't know existed
I've been doing wigs mustaches sideburns
you know beards merkins I can do leg
hair I can do our American whoo chest
hair I can pretty much do anything you
really want okay so based on this
picture of head
cavils moustache would you be able to
recreate that mustache oh yeah this is
easy this is like second year stuff in
the school
how much would of putting a fake
mustache on to make us a couple thousand
bucks for an entire ship for an entire
shoot not just for a day hold on hold on
does want to make sure that we catch it
on camera how much did you say that
would cost a couple thousand bucks
twenty two and a half million was his
mustache no 20 24 million okay
the way these CGI guys get away with it
is because nobody knows what they're
doing behind these computers they'd be
like oh it's gonna take us 16 hours to
put this dragon in here when it takes
him like two seconds the next thing you
know they're smoking cigarettes and
vaping outside for the next fourteen
that's what I saw I observed people from
what I was told
is that some somebody asked paramount
can we shave they said no that anybody
from Warner Brothers call you know
that's the thing I was waiting for it
when we said no shaving him the mustache
I was like are these guys are they're
gonna they're not gonna go for this they
went for it
even if they came with something like a
free lunch let me have a lot every once
in a while does a hobnob alright or just
like hey can I meet Gail no I think it's
gonna be fine
I think it's I think people in like 25
years or so people gonna look back that
and go silly mustache who cares it was a
fantastic movie you know
Academy Award winning Suicide Squad am i
right the backlash was immeasurable
breaking news this morning due to a
contract dispute Henry Cavill Superman
in the new Justice League movie will not
be able to shave his mustache Michael
Rapaport we can't remove that [ __ ]
thing yeah I saw the movie this time
well I couldn't even recognize my boy it
wasn't his chin look I can't
Superman has many ways to get rid of
facial hair one he could take a mirror
and you can get ray that [ __ ] right off
the face mustache no mustache black hair
brown hair I'm a gavel purist the only
thing that is non-negotiable for me is
the chest he's got to keep that unshaven
the DC
Cinematic Universe actually has a long
and storied history of questionable
facial hair removal going back 50 years
in fact Cesar Romero who played the
Joker in the 1960s Batman TV series and
feature film refused to shave his
mustache
so makeup artists had to cover it up
with white clown paint which is actually
better technology than that used in the
new Justice League movie there's the
phenomenon of the uncanny valley and
it's when a cgi based character is seen
on screen and the human brain just can't
process it research shows time and time
again that the human brain just rejects
it Superman's CGI mustache is the
scientific equivalent of getting stuck
in uncanny valleys gift shop where
they're only selling beef jerky for now
all that remains is what could have been
Superman is he's a god people have
symbols that they use to worship their
God me I have a Superman tattoo it is on
my shoulder I wear it proudly I do I
think people will forget Henry Cavill
mustache extravaganza and justice day
and time probably the news cycle is so
quick I'm sure everybody is already
thinking about the sequel to Wonder
Woman and that's not coming out for a
year and a half so I know this is a
little bit unorthodox but to say
something doesn't quite sell it as to
see something would you be willing to
show us Oh everybody thinks I don't have
a tattoo it's really funny I get those
tweets well someday hopefully studio
executives will learn that practical
effects are far superior to CGI oh I
think that one fans see this they're
gonna just their minds are gonna explode
from all the awesomeness that they won't
even think about the mustache don't
believe me I'm like Superman tattoo
whatever with the camera with this one
right here and make sure you see Mission
Impossible 6 July 27th 2018 Cruz is
amazing does action
everybody does action it's big action
[Music]
huh you don't see that
see right there boom $550 worth every
penny time has a way of healing all
wounds but can time erase a mustache
the good thing about DC fans is they're
super understanding they don't nitpick
at all they don't have any sort of
grudge against Marvel's success
critically or box-office so it's really
great that they could just exist
together and just kind of like this
awesome fandom harmony that I never
thought would exist but it warms our
hearts every time
[Music]
you